استقبل ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان مسائل احد مستشار الامن القوميه
الامريكي جاك سولفن وتم خلال اللقاء
استعراض العلاقات الاستراتيجيه بين
البلدين وسبلت عزيزها في مختلف المجالات
كما تم ايضا استعراض مستجدات الاوضاع
الاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشترك
كشف البيت الابيض في بيانيا استعرض مع
الامير محمد بن سلمان التقدم الكبير
لتعزيز الهدنه في اليمن اضافه الى قضايا
اقليميه اخرى رجاء مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي شكر لولي العهد السعودي على
الدعم الذي قدمته السعوديه للمواطنين
الامريكيين اثناء اجلائهم من السودان وفقا
للبيان كما استقبل ولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان نائبه حاكمه ابوظبي مستشار الامن
الوطني في دوله الامارات ومستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي ومستشار الامن القومي
الهندي وبحث اللقاء سبلت عزيزي العلاقات
والروابط بين دوالهم بما يعزز النمو
والاستقرار في المنطقه
ينضم الينا خبير السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه الدكتور وليد فارس دكتور وليد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابع ما هي اهداف
واشنطن من هذه الزياره في هذا التوقيت
دون شك هذه الاهداف باتت واضحه يوما بعد
يوم واشنطن تستعد لاعاده التموضع بعد
التغييرات السياسيه التي عصفت في المنطقه
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق السعودي
الايراني ولكن ليس هذا هو على الطاوله ما
هو على الطاوله بالنسبه لواشنطن الان هو
محاوله حل الازمه في السودان محاوله الحد
من انتشارها داخل السودان وبالطبع لا يخفى
على احد انه هذه الازمه تشكل مشكله
استراتيجيه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ليس للاسباب الداخليه فقط في السودان ولكن
ايضا على الصعيد الاقليمي والدولي مع وجود
مجموعات ذات تاثير من روسيا وغير اماكن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي الان موقع
الحل وبالتالي هذه الزياره هدفها الاول هو
التواصل مع القياده السعوديه هناك تسريبات
من من اكثر من موقع وصحيفه ايضا امريكيه
تحدثت على ان جاك سولفن ياتي بطريق حرير
امريكي جديد يعني
ليكون بديلا لطريق الحرير الصيني في
المنطقه الى اي مدى يمكن ان ينجح سليمان
او تنجح واشنطن في اقناع الرياض بهذا
البديل نتحدث عن الهند كبديل استراتيجي
للصين كما اتت هذه التكهنات يعني
هنالك كلام كثير في واشنطن وفي كل
الاتجاهات وحسب اي وسيله اعلاميه الى ما
هنالك الواقع الذي اراه انا هو انه في خضم
الانقسام العميق السياسي في واشنطن بين
الكونجرس خاصه مجلس النواب والاداره هنالك
من يتهم او ينتقد الاداره بانها اخفقت في
ملفات كثيره بما فيها العلاقات مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والتحالف العربي البعض
الاخر ينتقد توتر العلاقات مع اسرائيل
والان بالطبع مع هذه الازمه في السودان
البعض ينتقد الاداء السلبي على الاقل او
غير الناجح للاداره لمواجهه ذلك تتحرك
الاداره وبوضوعه للعوده الى فتح هذا الخط
الحريري او الخط الذهبي الجديد مع المملكه
لاقناعها بان تلعب دورا كما تلعبه الان
ولكن ان تبين انه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اصدقاء وحلفاء لانه المعارضه في
واشنطن تفهم الاداره بانها تخلت عن
خلفائها لم يعد هنالك حلفاء في المنطقه
يثقون بهذه السي هذا رد على هذا الانتقاد
وفعلا رئيس بايدن وفريقه يريدون اعاده
تحسين العلاقات خاصه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذه الزياره ايضا كان فيها
طرف الاماراتي طرف كذلك هندي موجود في هذه
الزياره وفي هذه المباحثات بالاضافه الى
وهم اتحدث عن يعني الامارات والهند اعضاء
في منظمه
هذه المنظمه هل يمكن بالفعل
ماذا تريد امريكا منها ان تكون بديلا
بديلا للصين بديلا لشانغهاي بديلا
لها تريد يعني مشاركه ماذا تريد امريكا
بالنظر حتى للتحديات الخطيره التي تمثلها
الصين يعني على امريكا والنظام العالمي من
وجهه نظر واشنطن
في بدايه هذا الحديث تكلمت عن التغييرات
الكبيره الصاعقه الى حد ما بالنسبه لوشنطن
عندما جرت كل هذه الاتفاقات والجميع هنا
يعرف ان الصين هي تحسنت من تموقعها اصبحت
هي الضامن لهذه الاتفاقات بين ايران
والسعوديه وقد يكون هنالك ملاحق لهذا
الموضوع ولان رياض هي الضامن او تحاول ان
تكون الضامن والحكم ما بين الاطراف
السودانيه دور المملكه انتقل من حليف عادي
او شريك عادي للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الى صانع قرار يعني المملكه بامكانها ان
تتكلم مع الصين مع الهند مع روسيا ومع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وان تكون لها
عقود مع كل هذه الاطراف هذا غير الموقف
لذلك اداره بين على الاقل ترتكل على
المملكه وتحاول ان تقنعها عمليا بانها
تريد علاقات خاصه ومميزه كالتي عندها يعني
مع اسرائيل لحد ما هذا لانه الوضع في
الشرقي الاوسط يتغير بسرعه تفوق سرعه
الامريكي فهذه محاوله للحاق بما يجري في
للحاق لوضعها كبديل يعني لطرد الصينيين من
المنطقه لما تمثله من اهميه استراتيجيه
الان في في طبيعه النظام والعلاقات
الدوليه دكتور فارس ام رديف
واقعيا استاذ خالد واقعيا جميع يعرف او
معظم الناس تعرف انه لا يمكن طرد الصين
يعني العمل الذي ادى الى دخول الصين الى
هذه المنطقه الخليج والهلال الخطيب وربما
دول اخرى في افريقيا هذا يعني كان له
تحضيرات وتهيئات منذ بسبب الخروج الامريكي
نعم وبسبب الخروج الى امريكا ربما كذلك من
المنطقه التي
ركزت كل شيء على اتفاق نووي الايراني
وتناست كل
شيء هذا الاتفاق هذا هو الثمن يعني هذا هو
الثمن الان ترى اه واشنطن ونفس الشيء
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا وروسيا كان بامكان هذه
الاداره ان تتصرف بشكل اخر لكي تحد من هذه
الحرب ولم يحصل ولهذه الحرب نتائج كبيره
كان في الرياض السيناتور الامريكي المعروف
نتحدث عن جاك سوليبان الرجل الثاني كما
يقال في واشنطن بعد الرئيس الامريكي كرئيس
لمجلس الامن القومي هناك ايضا زياره
متوقعه ومجدوله ربما لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي نهايه هذا الشهر الى الرياض
وكاننا امام حاله
انزال الدبلوماسي امريكي مكثف على
السعوديه في هذا التوقيت هذا التوقيت
دكتور قال يعني انه اشنطن بالفعل بدات
تتفهم
المتغيرات في المنطقه والتغيرات السياسيه
السعوديه الان بشكل
يعني اهميتها الاقتصاد الجغرافي الثقل
المنطقه ام انه
يعني هي ورقه تستفيد منها في الانتخابات
القادمه يعني لم تحدثنا عن التوقيت
دون الشات موضوع الانتخابات دائما يستفيد
من اي تحرك خارجي كل رئيس وكل رئيس معارضه
يستعمل الزيارات او العلاقات لهذا الموضوع
ولكن الاساس هنا انا اسميه يعني حج سياسي
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه لانها هي
تغيرت اولا في الداخل الاصلاحات الهائله
ليس فقط هؤلاء السياسيين ولكن اطراف
الثقافيين اكاديميين ابحاث يذهبون الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ويعودون ويقولون
هذه ليست السعوديه التي كنا عرفناها في
الماضي شيء كبير حدث في السعوديه بدا يؤثر
على القيادات السياسيه من الحسبين تكلمتم
عن السنه
من العايمه جرام عمليا كان هو ينتقد الى
القياده في مرحله معينه ولكنه فهم ان
التغييرات عميقه جدا جاك سولف طبعا يبرهن
انه الاولاد الامريكيه الان جديه في اعاده
علاقات اما عن نجاح هذه المحاولات هذه
يعني الحركات السياسيه الدبلوماسيه يعود
الى تفاهم بين الاثنين يعني اليوم القياده
السعوديه باتت هي في موقع الاختيار الموقع
الاختيار بالتالي الان كيف يمكن ان تفكر
الرياض في الاختيار يعني
من ناحيه الضرورات الاستراتيجيه هناك
تفكير
بشانغهاي هناك تفكير ببريكس على سبيل
المثال اليوم الحديث عن اي تو يو تو يعني
كمنظمه تحاول امريكا الترويج الرياض كيف
تنظر الان الى
وكاننا في حاله اشبه من صراع او حرب بارده
ربما اذا جاز لنا وصفه بهذا الشكل هل تتفق
مع هذا الراي
هذه حرب بارده بالنسبه للقياده السعوديه
او حتى للاداره الامريكيه هذه لعبه شطرنج
متحرك بسرعه جدا انا باعتقاد المملكه الان
هي في موقع انها تمد الجذور جسور بكل
الاتجاهات هذا لم يكن في السابق انها في
معسكر معين الان اصبحت هي المعسكر ربما قد
تنتقل الى موقع الحكم ولذلك انا متاكد على
اهميه ما يجري بالنسبه للسودان الرياض
ربما بجده الان هي التي تحاول ان تحل
مشكله غير قادره ان تحلها الرياض اقرب الى
واقع المنطقه من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور وليد فارس خبير السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه من واشنط